okay so we're at the National video game
arcade in Noctem and here we have our 3d
scanning photo booth we're using
technology to support the storytelling
surrounding physical object so what we
have here is our photo booth here and
the DSLR camera and what we do we're
trying to make 3d scans of wargaming
miniatures which is the example we're
using for the storytelling so what we do
here is we take quite a few images of
our molds on our turntable so from all
around from various angles and stuff
like that and then we use those images
through a bit of a magical
post-processing procedure to create 3d
models such as the one you see here
where we have a 1 inch tall mention just
like the gentleman back there and as you
can see just with images we have managed
to make a quite detailed 3d model of it
and see over here we already have a
gallery of quite a few of them and this
can just be embedded in any sort of
known platform you can take those three
molds and put them inside some other
virtual experience you could just leave
port them into Minecraft all because of
course there can be any size we can
throw them into virtual reality you can
walk around them see them in life-size
and potentially even interact with them
a bit of work but you could potentially
animate them as well so could we scan
anything in this such a thing could I
put my car keys in and you give me a
scan of them there are some limitations
for example we so it's not limited by
size really as long as you can get the
images you can do it for example drones
there's a good excuse actually for me to
get a drug it has a few issues so
basically what the camera can't see you
cannot scan so stuff that is transparent
is quite tricky
there are ways about it but it's quite
difficult and stuff that is shiny I mean
our brain is trained to disregard
reflections specular stuff so shininess
our mind just says yep we don't care
about that but the computer cannot do
that so stuff that is shiny they
effectively translated into just white
so depends on how shiny your khakis are
for example but it but with the proper
preparation and quite a few things are
doable ok
I don't want seeing my Carlos oh well
technically I could 3d scan your car
keys then
you print them because yes you could
really print any of these given Talman a
good free printer
now when that key would work in your car
depends on how do you turn so I will as
you're operating from the smartphone
medias so smartphone talks to the
turntable that talks to the camera so
I'll just get the sort online is that
stuff you've written as well or no no
this was off the shelf I mean while a
lot of the software their methods are
developed by us where we could we used
off-the-shelf technology so this is a
commercially available light books
basically on a very nice turntable but
it's actually our second version because
we did make one entirely in-house out of
whatever we could 3d print laser cuts
and various motors and stuff like that
basically it was a what I call the Mach
1 photo booth where you would place a
tag miniature with an NFC chip in it
into the photo booth and then it would
immediately start taking pictures of it
however it wasn't the best thing for 3d
scans hence why we went with our second
more refined model that you see here so
this was basically the procedure as you
can see turntable turns we get one
picture every 10 degrees so 36 images
per rotation and then all we really have
to do is change the height um tripod get
older right angles on it what does that
then give you that will give us quite a
few images so an average would take
about 100 images per object depending if
it's something that is non convex and
main you get different angles again
whatever the camera doesn't see they
cannot make a model off so we try to
make sure we get all the hidden parts of
the model then we throw that into our
software and we align the images so each
image needs to know where it is in
comparison to the other one so we'll
ideally get something like that as you
can see our three different heights
around the model then that will create a
sparse point cloud so basically the
between the images it will figure out
interesting points on the model so
features and put those as points in
space and once that is done we go
through a
rather more lengthy process where you
create a dense point cloud that is
basically the same thing but way more
points and space and that almost looks
like the object when it's done it isn't
a model per se a 3d polygon will model
but what it is is many many colored
points and space following that of
course we connect all the dots by
literally and we end up with a model and
then we make a crisp texture for it from
the images again that basically makes it
look like exactly what the object is so
for those Heights and calibrations that
all just worked out by the software or
do you have pick spirit it depends if
we're lucky and the model is quite
detailed
then we then it will pretty much suit
itself but again like most things it's
less it's less of science to be honest
and more a little bit of an art because
depends on the models depends on the how
the pictures were taken some are not
great so you always have to do a little
bit of tweaking manual work and tweaking
it so you can find our library of
scanned models online on our website and
as we go along with the project here
international video game again we're
hoping to grow that from about I mean
does the models we've got now 200 or as
many as people like to bring to us here
at the invade hopefully once we've got a
nice big collection of models not just
wargaming whatever you'll bring in as
fit we can do whatever we want with
these models so maybe a walkthrough
virtual reality gallery so use the HTTP
vibe to just be able to walk through
dense you'll even interact with the
models put them up on the website each
one with a little bit of tidbit of story
about who it is what is you know go over
the whole storytelling angle and then
we'll see so augmented reality so it is
all about tying virtual content to the
real world now there are a few ways to
do this and barring barring any
specialist equipment what you can do is
use optical techniques so in this case
which is